[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROGER MARTINEZ: If
you need to deploy
a large number of
identical virtual machines,
then Google Cloud's
Managed Instance Groups
is the best way to do that.
But its autoscaling
feature is what
takes it to the next level.
So let's take a look
at a configuration
to see what it looks like.
So let's start by going over
here to the navigation menu
and going down to
Compute Engine and then
over to Instance Groups.
So what I have on
this project is
one managed instance
group called web-app.
So let's click here to
go to the overview page,
and we'll see that
this managed instance
group has three instances only.
So each instance in
this instance group
is just an HTTP application
that returns some basic instance
information up here.
It also has some
built-in functionality
that lets me increase
the load on each instance
in the form of CPU utilization.
So let's initiate that on
each of these machines.
Now on the second
one, and the third.
So now, on each of
these instances,
the application is
consuming more and more CPU.
As you can see in
the Overview page,
I have autoscaling enabled on
this managed instance group.
Let's take a look at
the configuration.
So what we have is a
regional managed instance
group, distributed across three
zones in the US Central region.
And if you go down here,
you'll find the autoscaling
configuration.
If you have an existing
managed instance
group without
autoscaling enabled,
you'll have instead
down here a button that
says Configure autoscaling.
So I'm going to talk
about a few of the options
that you have in the
autoscaling configuration.
First, you'll want to choose
what you want your autoscaling
to be triggered by.
And you can choose from any
of these three metrics--
CPU utilization, load-balancing
utilization, and Stackdriver
monitoring metrics.
Depending on your
use case, you can
choose one of these
or a combination
by just clicking Add new metric.
Next, you'll want to choose
a minimum and a maximum.
I'll set my minimum
to 3, because I
have a regional
managed instance group,
and I want to make sure I have
at least one instance in each
of my three zones.
If you know that it takes
a while for your instances
to initialize after
boot time, there
are three settings that you'll
want to pay attention to.
So the first one is
the cooldown period.
So the cooldown period is
also known as the application
initialization period.
It's important because when
an application on an instance
is initializing,
the usage might not
reflect normal circumstances.
So the autoscaler will
not take into account
the usage data from
this time period
when it decides to
scale in or out.
Second is the scaling
controls down here.
So scaling controls
let you set a limit
to how quickly the autoscaler
scales your instance group down
to avoid any sudden drops
in the number of instances.
So this isn't required, but
it will help you optimize cost
by avoiding turning down too
many instances too quickly,
only to have to wait for new
ones provisioned immediately
after.
And finally, there's
predictive autoscaling.
So predictive autoscaling
feeds your instance
groups' historical
trends and current load
into a machine-learning
model so that you can
anticipate autoscale events.
So this is going to improve the
availability, because instead
of scaling up reactively due
to a metric threshold like CPU,
the instance group will scale
up in anticipation of the load
that it predicts will happen
based on real-world usage.
So if your application
takes time to start up,
this is going to be
very valuable in helping
ensure that your instance
group is ready to handle
an increasing load
when it happens,
without having to wait too
long for initialization.
Together, predictive
autoscaling, scaling controls,
and an accurate
cooldown period will
increase availability and
optimize spending on resources.
So if we go back to
our Overview page,
we'll see that the
autoscaler has already
started to provision
additional instances
to accommodate the
CPU load of the group.
Once that load is
reduced, it'll scale back
according to the
scaling controls
that I specified before.
That was a super quick look at
the autoscaling configuration
of a managed instance group.
When you're using
managed instance groups
on Google Cloud for
your application,
its autoscaling is a really
useful and powerful feature.
With the right settings
and configuration,
you can increase
your availability
while reducing costs associated
with compute resources.
[MUSIC PLAYING]